All right,
well today I'm going to talk about social security again.
There's going to be one more,
a discussion of social security later.
I'm going to defer most of my plan until later,
but,
uh,
I want to finish the discussion so that we totally understand the subject.
It will also allow me to talk about demography and introduced one of the most
famous models in economics called the overlapping generation model.
So in the 1940s,
so on named Maurice La an a a French economist introduced the overlapping
generations model into economics.
Okay.
He wrote it in French,
uh,
and it was sort of rediscovered by Sam has done in the 1950s.
Okay.
I'm not sure whether Samson had red outlay lay.
I think Samson may well have read La.
But Anyway,
Sam Hansen,
uh,
so these were 1947,
something like that.
1958 in which Samuelson rediscovered it and it,
it's a,
you'll see,
it's a very basic thought and it seemed at first to challenge everything that
we've learned so far.
So the idea of the overlap in generations models that time doesn't have a
beginning and an end.
Like we've assumed so far a time might go on forever.
Now,
whether or not you believe time,
whether there's scientific proof that time goes on forever or scientific proof
that the universe has to come to an end.
Let's face it.
Many of our institutions presume that time goes on forever.
The chief most important among them is social security.
Just the most,
uh,
which we'll see is the easiest thing to the model is designed to,
to understand the idea of social security's every,
the the pay as you go social security.
Okay.
The idea of Frances Perkins was that every young generation was going to give
money to the old,
but they shouldn't worry so much about it because when they got old,
the the next young generation will give them money.
Obviously if you thought time was going to come to an end,
the last young generation,
knowing that they were the last generation would refuse to give money to the old
because they weren't going to get anything back when they were old.
But then the second to last generation,
knowing that when they got old,
they get nothing from the last generation,
that young,
they wouldn't give anything either to the old and working backwards like that.
If everybody is rational and it's common knowledge that the world is going to
end,
nobody would ever participate in the social security scheme.
So it's clear that there's some thought that the world might end,
or at least there's a thought that it's not worth bothering about the world
ending.
So the overlapping generations model is meant to take that idea extremely
seriously
and imagine life going on forever.
So let's take the simplest example where this was a generation that begins.
So generations
last when they're a young and old.
So let's say we're at time a one here.
Okay.
And there's a generation that's young and a generation that's old.
Maybe I'll write it a little bit lower.
Sorry about that.
Okay,
so there's an old generation and the young generation and the endowment of the
old generation is,
is one.
The young generation has three.
One is young one when it's old three when it's young one,
when it's old three when it's young one when it's old.
So when you're young,
you have three,
three apples.
When you're old,
you have one apple.
The next generation when it's young has three apples.
When it's old,
it has one apple and so on forever.
So this'll be t equals one here,
two here,
three here,
four here,
et cetera.
So it goes on forever like that.
Now what did I lay in?
Samson?
Both basically say they both basically said,
look,
everybody when they're young is incredibly well off.
They're working,
they're productive.
When they're old and retired and feeble,
they don't have very much.
But what is it that the but,
but what can you do?
What were,
can you trained according to Samuelson?
What do the,
what does the old have to trade?
You know,
that it doesn't look like
Gotcha.
There's any trade that can take place.
So it seems like it would be very helpful if the old would give the new summer.
It was the young would give the old something and when they got old,
the next generation's old young could give them something so the young could,
can just constantly be making gifts to the old that was a la in San Francisco
idea and it's very closely related to social security.
So Sam Hansen got a little carried away with his idea and he said that social
security was the greatest and only true a beneficial Ponzi scheme ever invented
because you know,
in a Ponzi scheme,
this has gotten a lot of attention lately.
Thanks to our,
okay,
thanks to our uh,
famous,
uh,
Madoff.
So the,
a Ponzi scheme is basically a,
an investment strategy where you take the money that people give you and you buy
yachts with it.
And then when they asked for their money back when they asked for their money
back,
you tell them,
well,
you've,
that you've gotten great returns and you just hand them money that new people
have given you.
So they think you've gotten great returns.
And when that second generation of people wants their money back,
you tell them what you've invested in brilliantly.
I've gotten great returns,
but all you're doing is giving them the money that the next,
the third generation has given you.
And you kept going like that until finally you owe so much money,
you can't find new people fast enough to pay the people off.
And then everybody discovers the Ponzi scheme and it all unravels.
And,
uh,
the people at the beginning of May.
Dot.
Very well.
And the,
at the end who,
uh,
you know,
the second to last generation,
they've lost all their money and then lawsuits go,
you know,
lawsuits accumulate.
And uh,
it's quite interesting that in the Ponzi scheme,
the very first generations,
you know,
that benefited are not free because the whole thing was a ski,
the whole thing the guy made off running at knew from the beginning what was
going to happen.
And so those first generation of people,
there's no reason why they deserve to make their great returns.
They benefited from the Ponzi scheme.
So the last generation's suing Maydoff are effectively suing the first people as
well.
And so we'll see how the courts decided,
but often the people who get out of the Ponzi scheme early still are how liable
and the money's taken back.
So we'll see what happens in this case.
But anyway,
so obviously Ponzi schemes are terrible ideas in general,
but Samuelson said,
well,
when,
when life is going on forever,
then they might not have to be an end to the skiing.
It just keeps going.
This guy gives to this guy,
this guy gives to this guy.
There's no reason for the Ponzi scheme to end if you really think that the world
is going to go on forever.
And therefore social security is a great Ponzi scheme,
which is actually beneficial.
So Samuelson even wrote this and as a journalist for Newsweek,
and there's many,
I happened to be a little boy when he was writing this stuff and I remember some
of the articles and I've gone and found them.
And uh,
so he described the benefits of social security as a Ponzi scheme.
So,
you know,
this didn't turn out to be quite right.
And uh,
but it,
it certainly sounds plausible.
Another thing he said was,
he said that in the social security,
you know,
money you could think of as a Ponzi scheme money too,
because you know you have worthless pieces of paper,
you know,
but,
but you're willing to hold them when you're young,
you'll accept them for,
for goods because when you get old,
you can find the next guy who's willing to give up goods for your money.
And that guy's willing to take the money for it because when he gets old,
he can find the next generations young who's willing to give them goods for his
money.
So the money,
which is a worthless piece of paper never gets,
um,
never,
never gets exposed as being worthless.
Cause there's always another generation around to take it who thinks they're
going to be able to use it later.
So these are fascinating topics that Samuelson,
um,
discussed.
Okay.
But I don't want to discuss them in this class.
I want to discuss social security and so I'm going to do a variant of the model
that Samson never thought about,
which I think is a much more realistic model.
So I'm going to do overlapping generations with land.
Okay.
And you'll see that in this model,
I'm going to add land to it.
It's I think a more interesting model.
And we're going to,
and I'm not going to discuss the paradoxes of infinity because once you put
land,
even though time goes on forever,
the paradox is disappear.
So rather than spending all the time on the paradoxes and how they come about
and do make sense,
I'm just going to have land from the beginning and we're gonna,
it's gonna,
you know,
it will recapitulate in a nice way almost everything we've done this semester
and there won't be any paradoxes.
So what do I mean by land?
I mean suppose that land is a producer's one.
So this is land output.
Okay.
Produces one every period.
So there's another output call
apples that just,
you know,
a tree that's going to live forever,
let's call it land produces one every single period.
So here are the periods,
you know,
and this is what's happening and every period,
okay,
now land seems to make the situation much more complicated,
but in fact it will turn out that we can analyze this pretty easily.
So let me,
let me summarize again.
The model.
The model is that every generation,
every generation has one agent or a million identical agents.
Let's say every generation
has endowments.
So every generation tea has endowment.
It's generation t.
So it's an endowment at time t and at time t plus one
equal three one.
And let's say they all have utility and the utility of every generation t which
only depends on what they consume when they're young and old.
Okay?
Let's say is log a,
x t plus log white,
uh,
x t plus one.
Okay?
So everybody cares about consumption when they're young consumption with their
old,
they don't care about consumption any other time.
They begin with three apples.
When they're young,
they know they're going to have one apple when they're old.
Everybody's like that for generation t greater than or equal to one.
But generation a zero just has you.
So I can call that ut generation zero is only cares about consumption when old.
And that's that guy at the top.
Okay.
What I'll have to talk about,
the land generation zero owns the land.
Okay?
So that's the economy.
Very simple economy.
But it looks much more complicated than anything we've done before.
But we'll turn out not to be,
but it looks at it first glance.
So every generation has three apples.
One young,
one apple,
one old,
except the very first generation which has land.
And that in addition to his one apple,
one old,
and that a land produces one apple forever.
So we have to figure out what equilibrium is.
And then we have to look at social security.
And by doing this,
we're gonna understand social security much better than we did before.
Okay?
So any questions about this?
What's going on?
Then I'm going to try and write down what equilibrium is and then solve it.
And then we're going to talk about social security.
Yup.
Yes.
Oh,
well,
you know,
if you only can eat one good.
If I put log x one here,
it would be the same thing.
Remember if I take a monotonic transformation,
if I double the utility or take the utility e to the utility like that,
which is just equal to x one,
it describes the same utility.
The guy's not trading anything off.
There's only one good.
So more of the good is better for him.
It doesn't matter what we call it,
log x or x one is the same thing.
But that's a good question.
Let's call it log x one.
Make him symmetric.
Okay.
All right.
Well how would we define ECQUA?
Librium so there's financial equilibrium and then we're going to see if we can
solve this.
So what's happening in financial equilibrium?
Well,
it's kind of interesting here.
There's going to have to be a price of goods every period QT,
that's the contemporaneous price of apples.
There's going to be the price of land.
Every period.
Pie,
let's call it t.
So this is apple price.
So these are contemporaneous prices.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
With uh,
contemporaneous apple price.
Land Price.
Okay.
What else do we need?
Well,
we have to decide when everybody's going to consume every period.
So generation t what they're going to consume when young and one old.
Yeah.
And then there's generation zero what they're going to consume when old.
What else do I need to describe?
An equilibrium?
Probably yet.
So what's the budget said?
Everybody's going to face
a budget set for t greater than or equal to one is the set of all,
let's call it young consumption and old consumption.
So let's what you can,
so generation t cause we've got to consume something when young and one old such
that what?
What's the budget constraint?
Well,
when they're young,
if they want to consume goods,
they have to spend QT to consume goods.
So this is young.
Call that y.
Okay.
And when they're old,
they're going to have to consume,
sorry.
When they're young to consume that,
what else would they want to do?
They might want to old land.
So we could call that Pi ti and I better add a feta here for their holding of
land.
Hey,
hi t plus theta.
That's how much land they hold.
Remember how we did this?
Okay.
And then what?
What have they got?
Well,
they've got their endowment time.
T uh,
this is time t let's say this is generation t.
So their endowment is going to B e t t but that's three.
So I might as well write e t t just as three.
Okay.
And what else have they got?
Nothing.
Everybody comes into the world with just apples when young and apples with old.
So when they're young,
they've got three apples they can sell.
Okay.
They,
you know,
they can consume something.
So three minus Q,
the stuff they don't consume,
they sell and they can buy land with it.
I have all this time,
it's never happened.
MMM,
sorry about that.
Okay.
And then when they're old,
what can they do?
Well,
when they're old,
acute t plus one.
Okay.
Times Z.
Now are they going to bother to hold the land when they're old?
No,
because they're going to be dead and they don't care about their children.
All they care about is eating as much as they can.
So they're going to sell all their land.
So that's gotta be less than or equal to what?
And so here's the,
uh,
what are they going to get when they're old?
Will they have cute t plus one
when they're old and their endowment of one plus what they can sell their land.
Pi t plus one
times theta.
Whatever they bought the first time,
they can now sell when they're old.
Plus.
What else do they have
one last term.
What else is that?
So see what they do it.
Why would you buy land while,
because when you're young,
you're so rich,
you know you don't want to consume everything when you're young.
So instead of consuming your whole free,
you consume less,
you buy the land because the land is going to be worth something next period.
So what is it going to give for you next period?
What do you get next period from the land?
Well,
if you own the land,
you get what?
You get the dividend.
Okay,
so the dividend,
we have to multiply it by the price,
which on the one of the early classes I forgot.
And the dividend is one that's the dividend.
But how many dividends do you get?
How many apples?
It depends on how much of the land you had.
So if you had fade a units of the land,
you get,
you know,
if you had three acres of land,
you get three apples,
which you can sell for a price QT plus one.
You also still have the three acres of land,
which you can sell off when you're old.
Okay?
So that's the revenue you get by selling off the land.
And you also sell off some of your endowment may be,
and that's how you can buy when you're old.
So that's what the budget set is of the young,
of every generation.
And the budget set for generation t equals zero
is simply x one is simply Z,
we'll call it,
you know,
z such that,
what does this guy do?
Well,
[inaudible] Z has to be less than or equal to.
What does he have Q one times one plus he's got all the land.
So he's got one acre of land.
That's all the land there was.
So he's got high times,
uh,
Pi one,
he's got all the land.
So I'm normalize the land to be one acre.
Okay.
So Pi one times,
uh,
all land,
that's what that guy can do.
Okay.
So aqua Librium is a x,
t e
x t plus one
is best,
a four generation t in budget set t and x one.
So this is this and theta.
Okay.
An x one.
Did I write Fado?
I forgot to write feta and the definition of equilibrium here.
So I have to write a theta t.
They're also having to keep track of what,
uh,
what,
how much land they're going to have.
And this is t equals one to infinity.
Okay.
So the equilibrium is what are the prices every period of apples and land.
What does every age generation do in terms of their consumption and how much
land they hold and how much do you consume when you're,
how much is that very first generation consume?
It's obviously they're going to sell all their land to consume as much as they
can.
So the budget set,
so x one,
uh,
Saul's,
so z equals x one and y z Feta equals
that,
uh,
best regeneration t in this budget set and z equals x one is vast.
Okay?
Regeneration.
Zero in this budget set.
Okay?
Okay.
So to say it in words,
it's very simple and words.
And then we have this mathematics and it looks complicated,
but we're just gonna say it's gonna be very short to solve it,
even though it looks very complicated.
So the problem is this.
We've got generations who are rich,
one young,
poor,
one old.
There's land that lasts forever.
The only way people can save is by holding the land.
That's like holding stock,
that's holding something real.
So when they're young,
they're going to take some of their extra endowment because they're so rich.
When young,
they've got three one young and they're going to use it to buy land.
And when they get old,
they're going to,
uh,
sell the land and eat the endowment from the land,
the dividend for the land and sell the land and use that sale.
Proceed to also increase their consumption when old.
So there'll be taken care of when they're old because they're able to hold the
land.
And the question is,
how do we solve for the sacral Librium and so why is it,
so just to go back to Sam Wilson and all that,
why is it so interesting?
Well,
one of the reasons it's interesting is that people when they're young,
have to think about the price of land next period when they're old because they
know they're buying the land today.
They can see the price today,
but when they get old,
they have to,
you know,
why are they buying the land today?
Partly for the dividend next period when they're old,
but also for the resale value of the land.
So everybody is thinking to himself,
what's the value of land going to be next period.
And of course the value of land next period depends on what the young in that
period are willing to pay.
But they're thinking about what they're willing to pay on the basis of what they
expect to happen the period after.
So everybody has to think about the guy after him and what the guy after him is
thinking about what the guy after him,
his thinking.
And it looks very complicated.
Okay.
And we want to solve for an equilibrium in which everybody can rationally
anticipate with the guy in front of him is going to do,
which means rationally anticipate what that guy is rationally anticipating the
guy in front of him is going to do and you have to solve for the whole
equilibrium and see how it turns out.
Okay.
Any questions about this?
It looks very hard,
but it's going to turn out to be very,
very simple.
Yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
okay.
Because by the way,
I haven't said what happens to the uh,
dividend in period zero.
So actually I think that was a good point.
So he gets one,
he also gets the dividend in period zero.
I'm glad you asked that question.
I had neglected what happened to that v.
Okay,
so to answer your question,
remember the convention that we've made,
which holds in the market?
You know,
and it's one of the reasons for the breakdown of the market.
One of the reasons why the market seized up in the last year or two is because,
or the law,
you know last year is because when you buy a stock,
like the land,
you know,
somebody has to give the money and the other guy has to give back the stock and
you know the people buying and selling or not actually meeting each other and
you know,
simultaneously transferring money for the ownership of the land.
You know,
one guy,
he's in San Francisco and the other guys in New York and they're doing it
through some screen or something.
So the physical asset isn't quite changing hands.
So you have to make a convention about,
you know,
when do you say the deal has actually concluded?
So the convention is that we always use is that if you buy the land at time zero
you don't get the dividends at time.
T if you buy the land at time t you don't start getting the dividends until time
t plus one.
So if the young generation buys the land at time one,
they don't get the dividend until starting at time two.
So the very first dividend at time one is going to go to the old guy at time
one,
which I had left out here.
So the old guy does get a dividend.
It's the dividend at time one cause he began owning the land so he had it
before.
So he gets that piece of land.
He can even,
he,
even though he's selling the land at time one,
he still gets the dividend at time one.
And but generation that bought at at time on doesn't start getting dividends
until time too.
So I was an excellent question and it was an oversight of mine,
so exactly right.
Um,
okay.
And that's how it happens in real life.
Of course,
you know,
the,
the length of time might be three days or it might be one month or depends on
the security,
what the settlement rules are.
But,
uh,
there's always gotta be a break between when you buy the stuff and when you
start getting the dividends because,
you know,
it just takes time for the whole physical process to happen.
So in,
in,
uh,
in the settlement for,
so they say t plus three is a very common kind of settlement or t plus one that
means,
you know,
in three days or in one day.
And so if you're desperate for cash and you have to give up.
So anyway,
I won't get into,
we'll come back to this when we talk about the crisis and what happened,
but okay.
So people who are desperate to get stuff,
you know,
it doesn't start coming for a little while,
so,
okay.
Any other questions?
Yes.
Should I what?
Absolutely.
Okay.
Very good.
Any other comments?
All right.
Now how do you solve this?
Well,
let's figure out how to solve this.
So the first thing you can notice is that as Fisher never thought of having
infinite time and thought about social sec,
maybe thought about social security.
I'm not aware that he had any thoughts about social security,
but he thought we didn't have social security,
so it's unlikely he had been thinking about it.
So I don't think he thought about time going on forever.
But that doesn't mean his methods aren't.
He died by the way,
in 19,
uh,
47 I think.
Something like that.
So right around the time I'll lay wrote his paper.
So what is it that um,
what is it that uh,
he said all his lessons are going to hold true.
The first thing he said is that look in every period there's a queue there
accused on every uh,
side of things here or cutie cutie cutie plus one key t plus one QT plus one.
So a few just double if there's no loss in generality by taking all the cuties
to be one.
We have no theory of inflation yet because there's no money or anything.
So you might as well assume are measuring everything in terms of apples and take
QT to be one.
So without loss of generality,
as they say,
you know,
QT is equal to one.
And of course that means we have to,
we can divide every equation by QT.
So Pi t divided by QT would go here and we'd have a one and a one.
We divide this one by Qt plus one.
Still,
it's an equation.
We have z less than or equal to one plus Pi.
People swollen over Q t plus one plus one times one times theta.
So we just,
we normalize all the prices.
Okay,
so renormalize
all nominal prices.
Uh,
in terms of apples,
okay,
so one simplifying things as we can get rid of the soul.
Think of Pi.
T is the price of land in terms of apples.
So we just get rid of all the cues here.
Just assume that they're one.
And so we have this equation,
okay.
And now that means that Pi ti,
why is pi ti equals price of land at time t
in terms
of apples at time t.
Okay,
so that was a normalization we did many times before we said that,
you know,
we might as well assume the contemporaneous price.
We can't figure out what inflation is.
So let's figure that there's no inflation.
The price of apples is always one and therefore,
and we're going to measure the price of land in terms of apples.
So he got the same equation that now looks a lot simpler.
So the cues you don't have to really worry about.
We're just worrying about the pies.
Everything.
Period.
Okay.
So how
did,
what did Fisher say to do?
So we've got to worry about you.
What did Fisher say to do?
What was his,
whenever you have an economy of stock market economy like this,
what did he say to do?
What was his advice?
He said,
turn it into general equilibrium.
How?
By doing what?
Yup.
Okay.
So Fisher said Fisher's lesson,
forget about,
forget about assets.
Bye.
Pudding white pudding.
Their dividends,
dividends
into the endowments.
That's his first lesson is you see,
this is gonna.
This is a good summary of what we've learned so far in a second.
Last time was look at present value prices.
Okay?
So he says,
forget all these pies and things like that.
Just look at the present value.
So we're looking at p one p two p three.
Dot,
dot.
Dot.
We're a PT
price.
Uh,
at times at time,
you know,
zero let's say,
or time one,
doesn't matter.
Price at time.
One of,
uh,
an apple at time t.
Yeah.
So once you knew the presence of the endowment,
then I'm not going to write all this.
The endowment of all generations,
one and above is stays the same.
Three,
one,
three,
one.
But the endowment of generations zero is now one,
one,
one forever.
And the budget's said everybody's going to have a budget set determined by the
peas.
Okay?
Okay,
so now we're just one step from solving this.
So there's one more thing to notice before we can solve it.
So by symmetry,
so observe
that by symmetry.
We can hope
to find an equilibrium
equilibrium with
PT
plus won over PT,
e p a constant.
Okay,
so you know,
every generation is the same.
The only relevant price for a generation is the trade off between the price of
goods when they're young and the price of goods when they're old.
That's what Fisher said.
The veil of the,
of the stock market is just a means of transferring wealth between when you're
young and when you're old.
And really you should calculate.
All these guys have to calculate,
if I buy the stock now when I'm young,
it's going to cost me a certain amount of money and I'm going to be able to get
a return.
So the real rate of return,
right,
that they're all going to calculate is going to equal,
well,
they're going to by putting in Pi Ti dollars today,
they get out Pie t plus one plus the dividend one tomorrow,
right?
So tomorrow they're going to get Pied t plus one plus one.
So for every,
if they,
if they put in buy one share of stock,
it cost them piety and tomorrow they get,
you know,
patty apples when measuring in terms of apples and in the future they get pie t
plus one plus one apple in the future.
So that's the real rate of return.
That's like one plus r one plus r t.
Okay.
But we've,
we're going to assume that that's a constant one.
Plus r we're going to guess it's a constant and that's,
you know,
just one over this p that I told you about before the ratio PT plus one,
the present value.
So the the,
the,
this ratio is just the they interest rate between time,
t and time.
T plus one.
So Fisher says you don't have to think about all the stock market and what the
return on the stock market and all that's going to be really,
you're just trading off by doing all that calculation.
You're figuring out what's the trade off between time t goods and time t plus
one goods in the Fisher economy.
You don't look at the stock market,
you assume that everybody knows the present value prices and therefore the
tradeoff between time t and time t plus one goods.
And we're going to assume that's a constant because the thing so symmetric,
how else could it turned out except to constant.
Yeah.
Okay,
so now we're ready to solve it.
We've done all the tricks almost to solve it.
So what is an equilibrium going to be?
Okay,
so here's the equilibrium is going to be a very simple equation.
Okay?
At every generation you're going to have an old and a young.
So what is the total supply of goods and every generation,
how much goods are there?
There's one for the old apple,
right?
If you look at any generation like this one at time two,
there's that one.
No,
not that one.
Little less.
The one in the middle,
that's the one for the old guy.
Then there's the young guy who has three,
right?
And then the apple that the land produces.
So this is young apples
and this is the dividend
of apples.
So that's how many apples there are in the economy.
So who's going to be eating them?
Well,
there's going to be an old guy eating apples and there's going to be a young guy
eating apples.
So how much is the old guy going to eat?
Well,
the,
the uh,
old guys going to spend half as money.
And how much money does he have?
Well,
from his point of view,
he's just trading off when he's young,
against when he's old.
So from his point of view,
he's got three apples wanting to young plus one apple.
One,
he's old.
But that's worth to him the tradeoff between apples when he's young and when
he's old,
it's just given by
p.
Okay.
Divided by P.
I tell this,
this is the whole trick.
Okay?
So we have to spend a minute.
So this dawns on Ui,
this is true.
And now what's the young going to do?
The young generation,
what's their income?
Well,
they only care about the trade off between prices.
One when they're young and when they're old.
Okay?
So when they're young and when they're old,
they don't care about land according to Fisher.
They don't have to think about that.
They just have to know the price,
which we're assuming is p for everybody.
The trade off between young apples,
which are worth more than old apples.
So old.
Okay.
So to them they have the same income.
Three plus one p,
you know these peas referred to different time periods,
but we're assuming the same.
Here's the young,
this is the young.
Okay.
Yeah,
this is the young,
so this is divided by one.
So this is the young,
and this is the old.
And once I solved this equation,
we'll have the whole equilibrium.
But we'd need to understand this equation.
So where did I get this equation?
Okay,
so let's take any time period to like t equals two for example,
we know the total apples around that can be eaten or five that's on the right
hand side.
The old guys,
apple,
the young guys,
three apples and the the land producing one apple,
five apples and all know who's going to be eating the apples.
They're going to be old guys and they're going to be young guys eating apples.
So the old will be the generation one guys,
they're going to be eating apples and then the generation two guys are going to
be eating apples.
Now the generation two people,
they've got three apples at time two,
so they're looking at three but they've got expectations in their head.
They're going to think ahead,
what's the price of stock market today versus tomorrow?
Fisher says,
okay.
They do all that thinking.
They realize the tradeoff between PR consumption at time t when they're young
and consumption.
When time t plus one,
they're old.
That's given by the price.
P we've assumed there's a price p so they're going to say to themselves,
okay,
I've got three apples when I'm young.
One Apple.
One I'm old.
It's not worth the same in present value terms.
It's just three plus one p cause the old apple is not worth as much at time t as
it is at time.
T plus one is three plus one p I'm going to spend half of my income and the
price when I'm young.
I've assumed that's one.
Okay,
so that's what the younger doing.
The old guys now,
the old guys with their doing at time t depended on what they did when they were
young but when they were young at time one they knew there was a trade off
between time one and time two apples,
but we've assumed it's the same price trade offs.
We've assumed it's the same p and so they did the same calculation when they
were young.
They were going to spend half their money.
This je t'aime one generation is going to have spent half its money when it's
young half its present value when young,
okay divided by.
So when they're young they're going to,
they're going to do that when there are old.
Now they're looking forward to spending half their present value.
When they're old and the price of old of apples when they're old is given by p
relative to when they're young.
So they're gonna spend one half times the present value of their income divided
by the present value of the price of the old apple,
which is the apple we're talking about because there are consuming when they're
old now.
So their consumption plus this consumption equals five.
Now at least half of you must be baffled.
So ask me a question to see if we can get to the bottom of this.
That's it.
That's the whole equation.
As soon as we solve this,
we'll figure out all the prices and everything in the whole economy.
And uh,
so we're at the end.
But this is our,
this requires a little bit of thought.
So go ahead.
No.
Okay.
The dividend,
that's a good question.
And the dividend fit in here because yes,
there's a dividend.
Here's the dividend that got produced.
So there's an apple to be eaten from the dividend.
Okay.
Right now you're saying,
so it's very important question you're asking.
So it's correct what I wrote,
but,
but it doesn't sound correct.
So what he's saying,
the question is what happened to the dividend?
This guy,
this generation save this young generation,
either one.
This save the old generation,
the old generation,
when they were young at time one,
they bought land looking forward to their old age.
They sold the land and they got the dividend.
How come that's not factoring in to their demand?
That's his question.
Right?
Okay.
The answer is because that's precisely the point of what Fisher did.
Fisher said yes.
And the real world,
everybody is thinking to themselves like generation one,
I'm young now on buying the land because when I get older I'll be able to resell
it and also get the dividend.
But Fischer has thought ahead,
Fisher saying,
okay,
if the guy's going to think about pikey t plus one,
that's what will be able to sell land for and he's going to think about the
dividend is going to get okay and his rate of return is therefore divided by how
much he had to pay for the land today.
That's his rate of return.
But see,
the top thing is how many,
the bottom thing is how many apples he had to give up.
Pie Key there is how many apples he had to give up to get the land.
The numerator is how many apples he gets next period after selling the land and
taking the dividend.
So that ratio is the tradeoff between apples today and apples in the future for
him.
So if he says to himself with Fisher says,
the only thing the guy cares about is that ratio that trade off,
which we're calling p one over P,
that's the trade off.
He's going to have his in his mind.
Okay,
and so
what is his income?
This guy began with no land.
You know,
only zero began with the land.
Everybody else buys the land only as a means of getting to more consumption when
they're old.
So the whole point of fishers insight is you don't have to keep track of how the
guys managing to get the payoff when he's old.
All he's doing is he's recognizing a trade off of one plus R or one over p that
trade off between consumption when young consumption,
when old and all he can do is turn his concern,
his endowment when he's young into more endowment and he's old at that ratio and
it doesn't matter how he does it as long as we have the right ratio.
So Fisher says forget about the assets,
just keep track of the present value prices.
And these will tell you the ratio of transformation of goods when young to when
old.
And that's all you need to know to make a decision.
It's the whole point of Fisher says you don't need to think about the SSI.
After we get the PS,
we'll go back and figure out what the price of land is.
Any other questions?
Yes.
Wait again.
Second.
Yes,
because I,
I'm taking p as the ratio.
So p this PE
is here.
So it says if I had one apple at time t how many apples could I get at time?
T plus one
p of them because
right cause this ratio.
So for every apple I have down here,
I can get p apples at time,
t plus one.
So that ratio is the only thing that,
so I might as well call,
you know if the ratio of two prices as p it doesn't matter what their levels
are.
So I might as well think of one of them has one and the other one was p.
I could think of the first one is two and the second one is to p.
That would be the same thing.
Right?
So far I thought of the first prices too.
And this price is to p I put it to here or to here and a two here and it
wouldn't change anything.
So remember
we learned this the very,
this is why the lessons of general equilibrium,
they seem so obvious and then you put them in a slightly different context and
you realize how clever
Fisher was.
If you double all the prices,
you're not going to change anything.
It's the price ratios that matter.
So it's the trade off between apples when young and apples,
when old that matter.
If you assume that trade off is given by P,
you might as well as soon that the first guy for all we care,
he might as well as soon that he's measuring the prices when he's young in terms
of one and the prices when he's old in terms of p.
Okay,
those were very good questions.
It's a little confusing,
but when we go back to the original equilibrium,
you'll,
it'll be clearer I thing,
but so that's the only equation that we have to satisfy so we can solve that
equation now.
Any other questions?
Okay.
Let's solve that equation.
That equation is,
I'm going to multiply by two P so I'm going to get 10 p on the right hand side
might cause if I multiply by two P I get five times two PS,
10 p on the left hand side,
I'm just going to get three plus one p plus a three p plus p squared.
Okay?
And so if I multiply it,
you know,
I rearrange,
I just get p squared.
Oh my usual problems here.
P squared minus six P plus three equals zero
p squared minus six p plus three equals zero.
So p equals six plus.
And I'm using the quadratic formula,
which you might have two,
which I assume you know,
minus B squared minus four.
Okay,
so six squared minus four times one times three minus 12 over two which equals
six minus the square root of 24 over two.
Yeah.
So the square root of 24 is a little bit less than five.
So this is going to be a little bit more than one.
Uh,
sorry,
a little bit less than five.
So this will be a little bit more than one.
So the whole thing will be a little bit more than a half.
So let's say it's 0.55.
Okay?
Now how did I know?
Okay,
so here's a crucial step.
How did I know when I said six plus or minus?
Why did they take the minus?
Because if I had taken six plus this,
I would've gotten a gigantic,
well,
let's come back to that.
Okay.
So how did I know to take six minus that instead of six plus the,
so if this is the p and what are the prices,
what are fishers prices we've just solved for equilibrium and these prices are
going to be point.
Uh,
you know,
we call this one one maybe 0.5 5.55 squared.
Point five five Q Saturday.
That's Fisher says the prices are
okay and we can connect.
We can now figure out everybody's consumption.
Y and z.
What's why going to equal,
why is this thing on the right one half three plus one piece.
So it's 3.55 divided by two so that's a 1.775 okay.
And what's z?
You should check,
I'm going a little fast here for myself.
Three plus 3.55 divided by two is 1.775.
So what is z?
It's going to be one and a half plus.
No,
it's,
it's 3.5 call.
It's a 3.5 divided by 1.13.
Okay.
P is 0.5.
I'm going to fast for you.
A Hug P is 0.55 right?
I just got p.
So if I want to see now go back to consumption.
What's the consumption going to be when you're young?
It's going to be,
y is going to be three plus 0.55 divided by two which equals that three three
points,
right?
Three plus 0.55 that's the guy's income.
And he consumes a half when he's young,
that's 1.775.
And when he's old,
he's going to have the same income.
Uh,
so 1.775 divided by p.
Okay.
Which is,
so it's going to be 1.775 divided by 0.55.
Okay.
And that
you can see,
uh,
no,
that doesn't look right.
Uh,
divide,
not divide by point.
Yeah.
1.7 that divided by p and that's going to be a little bit more than three.
And so in fact,
if you solve it out,
it turns out to be 3.225.
Okay.
Did I go too fast there?
So I'm just solving,
I'm plugging in 0.55 there.
So it's 3.55 divided by half.
That was that number 1.775 divided by P,
which is 0.55 so you can see it's a little bit more than three because 0.55 and
to 1.7 as you know,
a little bit more than three.
In fact,
if you solve it out to some decimal places,
it's that.
Okay,
so we've solved what everybody does,
everybody.
Now we know what everyone's going to do.
The young are going to spend 1.775 are going to consume 1.775 uh,
they're going to consume 1.775 here they have an endowment of three apples are
not going to eat them all three only
consume 1.775 of them.
Okay,
and what are they going to do with the and then the old at the same time,
what are they doing?
They're consuming 3.2 to five but you notice that those things add up to five.
So the consumption when the young plus the consumption when they're old.
Okay?
So the consumption of this old guy there is 3.225 and you add the consumption of
that?
Yeah,
I went to high.
Their consumption of the young guy just under him is 1.775 the two of the mat up
to five that exactly clear as the market.
So what time to you repeat the same thing at time three et cetera.
So,
um,
yeah.
Okay.
So you see we've already cleared all the markets except the one at time one,
which looks more complicated.
But we've,
we've cleared all the markets now what's the price of a land going to be?
What's the price of land?
What to write that?
Let's write it here.
What's the price of land?
Which is going to be a constant.
How do we figure that out?
Howard Fisher say you've figured out the price of land.
So the price of land at time ones say,
what would the fishers say?
Yup.
That's one way of getting it.
Okay,
so what would he,
what's he paying for it?
Oh,
right.
So from this equation,
he spent 3.7 he spent 1.775 his income was three so what's leftover?
Okay,
what did he spend on land,
therefore?
Oh,
so the price of land has to be 1.225.
Now that's not the way Fisher suggest and finding out the price of land.
What did he say you should do?
What's the fundamental theorem and what is that?
Wow,
so the land pays one apple every period.
Okay,
so it's paying one plus one times p squared plus one times p cubed plus one
times speed.
The fourth right?
Because looked at from the point of view of time one you get an apple macs
period relative to the apples today,
that's worth p an apple in two periods.
It's worth p squared at a time.
One because you know an apple at time,
one at time two is worth p apples at time one and worth p squared.
Apples at times zero.
So you just keep doing this.
But this is a perpetuity and so therefore it's equal to,
okay,
yeah,
one over R.
Okay.
And we didn't.
So it's equal to one over R.
Okay.
And so what's our,
so we know that w so what's our,
how do we figure out what our is?
So what
one over one plus r equals p,
right equals 0.5.
So therefore one plus r equals one over 0.55 and r equals won over 0.55 minus a
one.
Okay.
And so this is a little less than two minus one is going to be like
0.81 or something.
Okay?
And you take one over 0.81 and you'd get the same number.
So all right,
so that's how fish.
So let's go back to,
so Fisher solved everything he said.
I mean the Fisher method solves it all.
It says it.
Well we haven't,
well let's worry about time.
A zero is what time one.
We haven't done that for.
So,
okay.
So what happens every period,
every period,
like from to onwards,
the young guy says,
uh Huh,
I've got three uh,
apples.
What am I going to do with them?
He says to himself,
well,
the price of land is 1.2 to five so I could,
you know,
I could,
uh,
I could eat some of the apples or I could buy some land.
And what does he decide to do?
He says,
let me eat 1.775 apples and spend the rest of the my money buying one acre of
land.
Now why am I doing that?
Because next period,
I know the price of land is going to be the same 1.2 to five and I'm going to
get a dividend of one.
So I'm going to be getting a rate of return.
We just calculated of 81% at that rate of return of 81% so this ratio up here,
okay,
this is another thing,
this also,
this number is equal to 1.225 plus one divided by 1.225 k.
That's also equal to a 1.81 remember our,
we just calculated over here,
where did I do are ar was 81% that's the same number here.
81% okay.
So everybody says to himself,
given that there's an 81% rate of interest,
I'm happy to pull the whole unit of land because at that rate of interest,
I'm just trading off consumption today for consumption.
When I'm old at the rate that I want to.
Okay.
And at time zero the market clears also.
So we cleared the market for every time to through infinity.
Okay.
And that was by this equation that was up here by picking the right P,
we know every market from t equals two onwards was clearing and Fisher would say
by Vol Ross law,
we don't have to worry about time one.
That's going to clear as well.
And sure enough it does.
You know it's a little bit different now it's just the old guy.
But the old guy with his land,
which is 1.225 pluses dividend of one is land,
which is worth 1.2 to five and his dividend of a,
well I wrote down the right price of land all this time.
Oh,
that would be bad.
Um,
okay,
so the old guy,
what does he do?
He has his,
he has his one apple plus he has the land.
So he's going to consume
the old guy has his,
oh I see the old guy.
So what happens at time?
Um,
one the old guy has his dividend that he had before.
Okay.
So he's got the dividends of the land cause he's owned the land,
you know,
forever.
So he gets the dividend of one plus heat.
So that's one.
Plus he has an endowment of one.
So he's consuming too now.
Plus he sells the land for 1.2 to five.
So that all adds up to 3.2 to five.
And then if you add the young generations,
1.775 that indeed clears the market at time one.
So the market's going to clear in every single period.
Okay.
But we only had to solve it for periods two and onwards,
which are all symmetric cause by Vol Ross law according to Fisher.
Once it clears from time to onwards without even bothering to check,
we know it would have had to work at time one and sure enough it did.
So as I said,
let's summarize now what we've done.
Okay.
And then we can start drawing the lesson.
So what we did is we started with a complicated model with land and people
having to look forward and expect what the price of land was going to be,
depending on what the next generation wanting to hold,
which depended on what they were gonna they were gonna think the generation of
that we're going to hold,
et cetera.
Very complicated stuff.
And we saw that to solve it was very simple.
You just do the Fisher thing.
If everybody's rational,
you can always turn everything you can forget about the acids and the land and
turn everything into present value prices and put the endowments so you forget
about all the assets and just put there the dividends into people's endowments
and look at all the present value prices.
Okay.
And the present value prices by symmetry where assuming just grow exponentially
declined exponentially.
Okay.
And then we could solve the one equation and figure out what that price was.
The Ex,
the,
the exponential number p that's,
you know,
to the nth power gives the enterprise as president.
Finally price.
So solving for that p we then cleared the markets.
We found out what everyone was going to do when young and went old.
And by plugging in now fissures formula,
the price of every acid as the present value of its dividends.
We figured out what the,
uh,
we figured out what the price of land was every period.
So we solved for the whole equilibrium and sure enough,
it clears and enact Librium.
Everybody's doing this calculation.
If I buy land today,
I'm going to get that rate of return on the land,
which corresponds to the pea.
It's going to be 81%
okay.
And so everything works out.
Yeah.
Okay.
So what's this got to do with social security?
There are any questions about this?
I,
I sense a little bit of puzzlement still.
You shouldn't be that far away from understanding it.
So let's hear a question.
What don't you understand?
Just point to an equation you don't understand.
Yes.
Good.
Brave of you.
How do we show that?
Okay,
so Fisher says that,
uh,
the way I solved it is I ignored the assets so I didn't pay attention to what
the assets were.
I just put the dividends in the endowment.
I didn't pay any attention to what people were holding of the assets because
Fisher says forget the acids all together,
just do the present value prices and augment the endowments.
And I found the present value prices by getting this factor p and then it was
just Peter the end and I found what everyone was going to consume.
That was it as far as Fisher's concern.
But then Fisher says,
okay,
once we found general equilibrium,
we can go back to financial equilibrium and figure out what the price of land
is,
which is uh,
the present value of the dividends.
So it's price is 1.2,
two,
five and the step I left out,
which you're asking about,
you can also figure out what assets everybody's holding.
So Fisher saying,
okay,
what assets are they holding while the guy,
you know,
he's spending,
he's consuming 1.7,
seven five here.
We figured out the price there of 1.225
okay,
so it must be that he's holding exactly one unit of the asset.
And so the asset market is clearing too,
but that's no accident Fisher saying if you,
if you clear all the markets doing the present value,
general equilibrium stuff,
and he'd go back to the financial equilibrium,
you're automatically going to be clearing all those markets too.
So I did.
I left out the step that you don't once.
It's because somebody's,
somebody's anticipated all that and got me to calculate the price of one and a
cheating way.
He said,
assumes they as one,
then figure out how much money you're spending on the acid.
What I should've done.
So he did that.
What I should've done is done Fisher's track of figuring out the price of the
asset,
which is 1.2 to five.
And then of course we know the guy must've bought one asset mortar to use up his
budget set,
but that clears the market for assets.
But Fischer knew that was going to happen.
It always has to happen.
That's the beauty of what he did.
Yes,
yes.
So the point is so that you,
thank you.
I'm coming back to exactly that point.
So the point is,
when you look at the present value of land,
it's going to be p plus p squared plus Pq plus p to the fourth.
The present value of land had better be finite.
Okay.
So in other words,
p has to be less than one.
Otherwise the value of land would be infinite and it wouldn't make any sense
because in the very first old guy with an infinite amount of land,
infinite value of land would buy more apples in there.
Possibly.
We're in the world.
So you know that the interest rate,
the real interest rate has to be positive.
If the real interest rate,
we're not,
we're less than zero.
You would have to uh,
Eh and s and you had some acid that paid a constant dividend forever.
That acid would have an infinite value.
So the presence of land,
which pays a constant,
uh,
acid forever forces the rate of inch,
the real rate of interest to be positive.
So Samuelson and all this talk of negative real interest rates,
it can't really happen if you think that land is going to lie,
you know,
land is going to pay some dividend probably forever.
So there's going to be a positive real rate of interest.
Yeah.
Okay.
And so it means,
and social security,
if,
if like the young give up one and the uh,
the,
the young give up one to get one back when they're old,
they're always going to be losing because there's a positive real rate of
interest.
And so every generation has to lose.
Okay.
So were the exactly the point of all,
it's all,
it's precisely the point because of the presence of land,
you know,
that the real rate of interest is going to have to be positive.
You know,
Fisher never made this argument.
He said it's impatience and you know,
maybe if people are incredibly patient,
it could even turn out to be negative.
But a,
or if you know,
if output was bigger next period than it is this period,
you could even have a negative rate of interest but not so when you have land
with a constant dividend forever,
then if the interest rate is constant,
it better be positive.
Otherwise the land would have infinite value.
Okay.
So it's a new argument for a positive rate of interest.
You have to have the,
the land has to have a finite value.
Okay.
Any other questions?
So when you solve for a couple of EADS,
you're going to do it very easily.
Now,
uh,
I mean after we've done that a couple of times,
this will seem very easy for you.
I know it seems a little confusing now,
but let's just do a couple more thought experiment.
Suppose we do social security.
What will happen with social security?
How does that work?
What is social security mean?
Well,
social security means the young give the old something.
And until now,
we talked about it as if the young could give the old part of their endowment,
you know,
the young pay taxes and the taxes get handed over to the old guy that's pay as
you go.
And we talked as if it wouldn't change the equilibrium,
but we said at the same time that social security was the most gigantic program.
You know,
any government anywhere in the world has ever adopted.
So,
oh and it's on the size,
you know,
all the,
the,
the giveaway was on the side was bigger than p for a year,
you know,
17 trillion compared to 12 14 trillion.
So clearly it's going to have an effect on the interest rate.
So we ought to take that into account if we're doing a more careful analysis of
social security.
So what would social security do?
How would I take into account social security?
Suppose every young person gave one unit,
you know,
one apple,
the old guy at
the same time.
How would I figure out what happened in the new equilibrium?
How would the economy change?
What would I change and solve differently?
Well it,
all I would do is I would change this to a,
to every young guy now only as to apples when he's young because he given one of
them to the old and the old would have to.
So all the way through here,
I would just change all this to a Tu Tu,
Tu,
Tu.
Right?
And that's what I would do.
That's all I,
that's the change that I have to resolve the equilibrium.
So how would that change?
What would I change in my one equation?
Well,
the apples and the economy,
the young apples,
the guy's only got to what the old apples like olds got two and there's still
one apple coming from the land.
So that's still five.
But now every generation is going to be behaving a little bit differently.
They're going to have to,
when they're young and too,
when they're old,
this guy,
we have to,
when he's young and too,
and he's old and otherwise it's the same thing.
So I just resolve for the equilibrium.
Okay.
And so if I resolve for the equilibrium multiplying by two P,
I'll have two plus two p plus four p
multiplying by two p.
So no,
I might get for,
sorry,
I'm just confused myself.
I multiply by two P,
I've got a two plus two p multiplying by two P.
I have to pee here.
Okay.
Plause multiplying by two P.
I have two p squared here.
I hope I'm doing this right.
Okay.
I've got 10 p on the right like I had before.
So now I've got two p squared
minus 10 P and that's four pieces.
So it's still six Pete looks like plus two equals zero and so p equals six plus
or minus 36 minus eight
over four.
Okay.
And so that,
I hope I did that right.
Um,
I hope checking it.
Okay.
So that turns out to be,
that turns out to be a p is 2.8 no,
social security p is 0.38 now.
So this equals,
now that equals 0.38.
Okay,
so six minus square root of 28th.
Um,
okay.
So let's like,
so it's working out pretty much they'll s okay.
So,
um,
so 0.38 is the new price.
Okay.
So,
so therefore the interest rate one over one plus r equals 0.38.
So what do you think happens to the interest rate?
So our now equals,
okay,
before I write it,
you can figure out what it is yourself in a second.
Do you think the interest rate went up or down in the new economy?
What would Fisher have said?
Oh,
they went way up.
Okay.
And so it's actually 347%
okay.
So the interest rate went from 81% to um,
no,
that can't be right.
Went to a 161%.
Okay.
So the interest rate went up.
So the loss,
the loss is even worse than it seemed before.
Remember,
in present value terms,
when you're young,
you give up one and when you're older you get one.
And so you lose the present value.
So the present value of that trade is this plus the hat over one plus R.
Well,
now that our has gone up,
you're leaving losing anymore.
So social security at the current interest rates looks bad for every generation.
After you do the social security and everybody understands it's happening,
it's going to be even worse in terms of present value.
Okay,
so social security hurts.
So social security,
again,
everybody is giving something when they're young to the old.
So the guy at the very beginning at the very top gains a lot.
Everybody else,
every other generation loses.
And you can compute the utility after social security compared to both for
social security.
And it goes from something like 2.7 to 2.3 so there's a substantial loss for
everyone's utility except for the first generation.
On the other hand,
we rescued the first generation.
Now there are two more experiments.
I'm not going to be able to finish today,
but I'm going to mention them.
Experiment.
One is,
suppose we had more and more children,
every generation.
How would we take that into account?
Well,
it's very simple to take into account.
The same thing with a trivial change.
You can figure out what happens with more and more generations with more and
more children.
Okay.
So I'm going to go back to three.
One,
this only takes me one minute.
Sorry about this.
I know time's running out,
but let me just finish this story.
Okay.
So if we had more and more children in every generation,
so every 30 years,
let's say the population doubled,
that's not such a high growth rate.
You know,
per year you'd have six and two here.
Okay.
And then he'd go up to 12 and four.
And we'd have to,
but,
but again,
it's,
it's all exponentially growing.
And the dividends would also be growing.
So this would be two and four,
eight and 16,
et cetera.
Okay.
But as you'll see in a second,
the weight,
I won't do it this time.
Next time you'll see that it's very easy to solve for the new equilibrium.
We just put a,
you put a double here thing because the young,
they're twice as many young.
Okay.
You just solve it and you do the whole thing.
And what happens is social security isn't solved,
even though Sam Munson was in a way wrong again,
even though they're too okay,
even though they're two young people for every old person.
So every young person only has to give up half an apple.
You only have to give up half an apple when you're young.
Okay.
And when you're old,
you still get a whole apple back.
Sounds like now you surely should gain,
but the point is you don't because the rate of interest gets higher.
And then we're going to have generations that alternate and size.
But all these are very easy to solve once you figure this out.
So today on Thursday,
you have to solve a problem just like that.
So you get the hang of it.
Just one problem to do for Thursday.